lastly problem types and I'll give you
some examples here okay there are three
basic kinds of triggered any proofs that
require very slightly different
approaches sure the most report one is
the one you will see 90% of the time you
see them already
it's where you have something like this
board okay you're going to let the
outside you go right inside one side is
clearly the side you're supposed to go
towards because all simplified and nice
and neat and then the other side get the
best and you're like oh this is the one
I should start on you just have to
choose it carefully and then just go to
the other side so 90% of the triggers
that you get look like this so all you
have to do is make the right choice
that's okay but there are two other
kinds of versions an option though you
want to do with them the first one is
this one okay what you end up getting is
something where both sides look like
they've been really nicely simplified
and you're like what is the obvious
place to start right let me give you any
helpful on digital if you can you right
now this one is telling you may actually
have sales already
okay now wick is because I just push you
into it there is something you could do
you're immediately like oh okay I should
try this but it's not obvious at all
which side you should start from they're
both looks pretty simple even if you
can't consult at evenings apart okay so
let me show you how this is going to
play out
I'm going to begin with the left hand
time I should have said this is not a
required the proof I'm going to begin
with the left and because I've seen it
question before I'm going to go to
records where I need to go so maybe you
don't see the evening
that's okay just for the purposes of
illustration okay I notice that those
two things on the denominator if I think
about what they are like what they
represent the your ratios right or
reciprocals and ratio this one is one
over cause and this one is slide over
cons so I see all both of them happen
over cause in there right so I can
simplify that I can get rid of those by
multiplying the top and the bottom but
cos theta do you see that that'll make
things as easy to point so I'm going to
write that here you see I have not
changed the fraction
I just made an equivalent fraction but
it will make my functions slightly easy
to deal with
okay so numerators nice and simple
that's all good one the denominator set
transcoders is whatever cos x cos so
that is one caveat is cider because so
slider requires pub cos is fine now this
point you're picking I don't where I'm
going this doesn't look helpful at all I
meant to have like two things on a
numerator and the denominator so what am
I going to do with this okay again I'm
going to show you something which is not
obvious to begin with but you see why
I'm relating it to the point again I am
going to multiply the top and the bottom
by something but see I'm going to choose
it is 1 minus sine theta
now the question you're many of you will
be begging you how on earth did you
think to do that where did that come
from
I'll explain that in a second let's just
see what happens okay on the numerator
what do you get call it say no and I'm
actually just going to leave a factor on
you don't do this game very much by
multiplying through could it's not
likely to simplify with each other you
just do this what about the denominator
I have differences square sheet design
these two here are sort of conjugates
aren't they
so this is going to become
sign quit now it's starting maybe to
unravel in your life that denominator I
can use one of the identities that I
recognize which one this is a version of
the plaque the greater if you remember
the one that I think is work couple to
recall is this one is the primary one
but you can see I like to rearrange this
a teeny bit subtract sine theta sine
square theta from both sides you know I
hope there it is right so I would
classify this as all this diversions
were planned to go ahead of you so down
here I can write cos theta one my
employer only because squared
are you happy with that okay now I'm
actually is not going to finish this job
because I think you can actually number
one I run out of space aboard number two
I think you can see we're going
countries right I'm going to lose the
confit off the top which means I lose
one of the clothes beat is down to four
what does that leave me with one time to
the [ __ ] master yeah the one over
Claus becomes sick the slider of the
clause becomes ten and your heart okay
now here's what I want to point out
that's interesting about this question
and different from this client okay
we're easy to heart you just see okay I
understand simplified down as high as I
can but in this case are not one but two
occasions I had to make things messy on
before they became Juanita does that
make sense of the analogy I like to draw
this to do is if you've ever basically
never desk right and most of us do not
have very clean desk your room becomes a
lot Messier like stuff just goes from
the desk to the floor providers is
everywhere things have to get Messier
you have to sort of real racing before
you can actually take off this belongs
in this pile conservativism whatever and
so now I should help me think this one
is easier what was the clue that told me
I should multiply two by this
cancer fraction okay so I'm trying to
get rid of these fractions that suppose
even though it is someone like you
messier than this that's the first clue
that gave me to do that and you're
Russian or thought well yeah multiply my
content cause if you spend a weekend
with whatever class plus I know because
you get one all that occurs around yes
so you get to this eventually with you
it's going up with the same thing I did
yeah I find that that works however i
lolled avoid like the plague because i
see students making so many problems
with it i'm dealing with fractions of
fractions i want to avoid that wherever
I can because students tend to remember
at all but you look at the same thing if
you do it if you execute it correctly
all right now in time not here whether
it is what about this one this is much
much obvious what clues mean the
question tells you this is where up
right ahead this I can think of Lisa to
it we are trying to get to a point we
can use it again okay number one you
think at this point here when this is
what I've got written my regular
strategy just failed it right I've
gotten down to sines and cosines I've
simplified out whatever I can and then
I'm like that it's as simple as it gets
right so I've got to search from some
other identities that I can use okay
that's good it's not so nice helpful
because as we progress you're going to
learn more and more for me and you're
going to be like which one wants to push
to use there is something that other
more obvious that tells you I've got
I've got a multiplier left over like
this any suggestions yeah Jake what is
an important next one very good
so what Jake is done if he's been
looking at what he fishes with and
there's no denominator here I'll stop
okay so this is the key right now it's
got to go in some ways some shape some
form okay so therefore in order to get
rid of it I've got to multiply this guy
by something in order to manipulator and
I can see oh there's a confit on the top
maybe that's got a district answer for
me on the bottom and that's what leads
me to think I actually need to practical
in again this year okay
this happens frequently you're going to
introduce you have to get up to
recognize the type occur in any sort of
hiding there
so itself leads sort of onion even
colors and you've got to multiply
something by something to bring it up
okay the first thing I'll point out is
actually this question is not as hard as
it looks once you see the solution you
don't know okay I can manage that but
then again you only see how easy
something is after you have it is that
not before so it's no use to you right
now that actually there isn't easy
solution to it if you can't see it so
when you've got something of this form
I'm like I'm going to solve it for you
I'm just going to give you the main
strategy not obvious which place to
start and no matter which side you start
on you're going to do what we did before
you're going to start to realize right
bless you and you're not going to get to
the other side because this is not
simple right
so therefore what are you going to do
here's my question I need a bit of space
if both sides are hard
if both sign behind just start with
either type it doesn't that right you're
going to have to be able to do some
spigen items so just underneath your
your top whatever hand side I would say
that one is satellite line
okay pepper sauce doesn't matter you can
do something you can recognize some
items you can expand something now that
I've applied go a size you can simplify
out as many things as possible
if you can't see any obvious path like
we did before like Jake mentioned oh my
god get it rezoned Dominator so you
can't see that don't worry just like get
to this point and then if you don't see
anything else just stop
I can go as far as you can okay then
after that try the other side
I think now I'm going to provide them
you're not finished yet right
presumably if the other side is also
hard you will start to simplify and
eventually they should connect you
should get exactly the same thing on
both sides so okay no joy right okay so
here's what I mean here's what my truth
would have to look like I'd like you to
write inches underneath okay you're
required to prove a left-hand side and a
right-hand side okay so this is what you
presented with you like this others flip
the coin that's not with the left okay
you start to simplify eventually you get
down to some simple version of build
left hand side okay and you'll like now
I don't see anything this will be the
main thing that's the problem
just like we geometry crucial I just cut
I know there's something in there this
country which enables us to work with or
which side whatever you get this point
men you are stuck that's okay their
problem over here on the right hand side
aside from my normal working I'm going
to start on the right hand side under
start to work with that and presumably
if you do seem dry you should get in the
simple left hand side okay so you'll
boil down to something in fact both of
these thinking most efficiently you can
prove that both of them actually
all the patrique functions actually
cancel out and
one which is a bit weird okay so you can
simplify this guy you'll end up here
you'll simplify this guy you end up at
the same spot haven't finished your
proof now that you know you can get from
the right hand side to this simple
version don't think you can go in the
reverse direction right you can go from
this so that you just literally reverse
your steps and you attach it to the main
body of your proof right so these steps
over here you can just do them in
Reverse these guys over here are and
then you will actually end up on your
right-hand side okay the reason why this
is more successful is because we're good
simplifying we can do that
our overall strategies that I mentioned
before you will get better and better at
ballot them so going in this direction
is fine but once you've gone in that
direction now you have all your steps we
just have to put them in the opposite
order
okay so I've never write to you reverse
and then of course you'll end at the
right hand side because that's where you
started okay so these are it like I said
in most cases this is what you'll get if
you guys are extension to what we've
been dealing with so far still just the
two unit identity so you'll frequently
see these as extensions in an exam which
is designed to take the harder version
of Fortuna identity okay
a little later on this term we move on
to the identity are just basically
extension only but we're not quite there
so even watchful for these guys which
are a bit trickier